- Kinda look like little
mini hats in a way.
(upbeat music)
- I don't know, I think they're great.
I think they can be very practical.
- This is much larger than my nipple.
It's a sizable part of my boob, actually.
(upbeat music)
- My friend and I were at Burning Man,
and she left her pasties
on for a day and half,
and they actually started
to take off the skin.
- I think of Miley Cyrus,
when I think of pasties,
like, rockin' it.
- I think this is gonna
be pretty scandalous.
- I'm ready for my nipples to shimmer
like a little star.
- I don't know why we have
to cover up, but guys don't.
- I don't understand why the nipple
is the weirdest part of the boob.
- My mom always said I had
nipples like my grandmother.
I never really understood what that meant.
- I feel free.
There's nothing on me. This is so weird.
- You know, I was hoping
with these green stars
I would get kind of an Ariel look,
A Little Mermaid look,
but it's not doing anything
for my boobs at all.
- I feel like if somebody was here
I'd shake my boobs in their face.
- Oh my God, you guys!
- These are so big that it almost looks
like a really tiny bikini.
- I am the most letdown of
a stripper there ever was!
- They're like, why did
you put these on us?
- I can't stop looking at them.
I don't wanna turn away.
- If you're gonna go this far,
you might as well just go all
the way and show your nipples.
- So much more movement
can happen with this.
- You'd have to wear it for a long time
for it to be worth it, and I don't think
I'd really wanna go without
my bra for that long.
- I think that the nipple should be free,
in that we shouldn't say that,
"Oh, if you show one
centimeter more of your breast,
"you are slutty, or
bad, or wrong, or dirty,
"but if you show one centimeter less,
"it's totally fine and it's sexy."
- It's kinda fun, though.
I'm not gonna lie (laughs).
- I think that every chick
should have some pasties.
- I guess, if they make you feel sexy,
you should wear them.
(upbeat music)